I said this last night actually I think
I was more generous when I had no money
then now that I have a ton of money
not a ton ton I shouldn't say that yes I
have a little bit of money compared to
what I used to have I'm saying I have a
ton I was I was broke broke when I first
moved here I was so poor really I feel
like everybody's been insane you know I
didn't have money now I was born less
money in the sense of like don't ask me
being okay with buying stuff or giving
it away to people and stuff and now
anymore the floors I might lose it yeah
I'm Way more for because I'm a fear I'm
gonna lose it and they're saying I'm
more generous me too I was but I'm more
generous than I wish I was I get so
nervous I'm like they're gonna take it
away from me oh nice yeah I'm Way more
gee I don't know why I'm worried they're
gonna take it away from me
did you grow up with a lot of money no a
lot I mean we were fine we were very
comfortable
my parents I owned a dance studio I
guess I guess I guess I don't know what
my anxiety stems from I get nervous yeah
oh my god yeah more than one how's your
balls dope yeah yeah no no my parents
are very calm we were we were fine - I
just feel like I went to public school
yeah we do beat us yeah guy was probably
one of the more wealthy upper class was
upper-middle class yeah yeah you know
but um yeah my parents at a dance studio
so it's like it's not like we're [ __ ]
mobile more than one not one one dance
man but my part my parents had like a
really good business and they like
understood the structure their business
they like defined their business and
then all these other feel your business
yeah probably from them just seeing them
work tired like I guess I grew up fine
it's just I get I I guess I started this
game so poor that I could I get scared I
mean that's just beaming I I gotta go I
understand that there's a fear of going
down yeah you get scared yeah and it's
like I think it's why a lot of times
athletes have come from nothing spend
all their money because they're not
afraid of nothing because they've
existed and they've thrived in nothing
yeah because because they went to zero
to 100 we're in this game uo 0 to 10 to
20 and act on a 10 like this this the
stand-up game but it's like what at zero
right like you don't mind zero I don't
miss it right I don't [ __ ] this
Lear's and again you don't want to go
there I don't miss it you never want to
go - no you're the one I'm is sharing a
bathroom with three men I don't miss
that kind of [ __ ] this this is different
they'll be so heartbreaking if we went
back down to zero be funny though it
would be hilarious I get a new hour out
of it Kalen would love it Kath would
[ __ ] love it
Callan that racist bigot there's a I
think what happens is
once you realize like you can make money
from nothing you start to have less
economic anxiety and I think when you're
in like the Hollywood matrix like for so
long you've been auditioning and getting
pilots and getting shows and all these
things you're like [ __ ] I hope I don't
get another show I hope I get yeah but
your money is in their hands
and I think the more that you get into
podcasting and the more that you start
you know you continue selling out in the
road and doing these things and you
start going oh I'm making my money yeah
control it but be fair you know this -
this is the first time this has happened
in our industry in a long time it never
used to be this and ever yeah so I'm
saying like that's why the nervousness
is there cuz I'm like never used to I
used to yeah yeah yeah literally what
farmers do we plant seeds yeah and then
go get the crops at the end of the
harvest right so like when you're a
farmer you have confidence you're gonna
eat because you're like I just plant it
right put in the word soil yeah exactly
guy at the grocery store that needs to
buy the pumpkins is like I hope we get
pumpkins yeah yeah I hope we get
radishes or whatever it is so I for me I
think that's what started happening when
I started when I went okay I can do this
I can create content I can put it up in
places and I can create revenue to take
care of my family take care of my
friends take care of my parents
whoever need needs money whoever needs
anything and I know I'm doing it I'm not
relying on someone else that's the
reason why I wanted kind of out of the
typical Hollywood [ __ ] was like I can't
live my whole life hoping someone
chooses me well it sucks it's not about
your special that cuz I think i'ma say
that I think they have other friends
through the same way like Oh anti Howard
anti Hollywood not like we're just gonna
be there all Netflix coming centrally oh
I'm not like in it I'm not in science I
Hollywood it should I'm not saying and
timing but when when you go against the
Machine and then soon the Machine goes
we'll take it you're like all right do
it my god that you got to break the
Machine customer is you break the
machine so you like my nice imagine
totally yeah so it's like the new
special will be I think one of the first
specials that is like a product of new
media right and they got you know back
in the day I think the network's deserve
the lion's share the money because they
had the platform they had the
that audience which is most important
they had the audience we couldn't get in
front of people unless the HBO said here
get in front of people right and they
also had the ability to shoot it right
they had all those things and we were
the ones that put together the content
we still do that now we do the content
we have a platform that we want you to
write or Twitter Instagram all these
other things we could shoot it if we
want I do it every single weekend with
my guys and we have the people so if you
want me to go on your network the page
structure got to be totally different
right it's got to be totally different
when I told people to like put out their
content for free I don't think your
contents worthless you define the value
of your content right just because you
put it out for free doesn't mean it's
worth nothing no yeah yeah it's worth it
so it's like so for me I wasn't gonna do
a deal
I went from nobody wanted to do a deal
to people being interested in I wasn't
gonna do a deal until the deal was right
and I'll tell you stories your ideal
yeah yeah I mean it's pretty crazy how
much I'm gonna tell you exactly how much
no no no no I'll tell you what happened
about I tell Sofia exactly this job I
know so [ __ ] bad okay so this will
happen I came back from a long time ago
before I came here I did remember a drop
use from assist and I was here yeah I
think was the first time I ever did this
one like that same time I was here I was
about to drop you since I think it was
the next week
mm-hmm I had a meeting with commie
dynamics right your production company
and get it they get new media they
[ __ ] understand it and there are K we
want to have view so missus can you not
put it out and I was like that's gonna
be a million dollars and they were like
what are you talking about you don't put
it out on YouTube I was like not it
needs to be on YouTube so it's a million
dollars if you guys want it and they're
like okay we'll just give us a few days
I like it's going up Sunday so I in the
comedy world needed it in a weird way
like the culture needed it it was just
like a big [ __ ] you and you just need to
shake some [ __ ] you know and then I go
to Montreal I have a good Montreal I'll
come back Netflix makes me an offer for
to do stand-up to do the degenerate
whatever like 15 minutes all the new one
yeah yeah okay the other doing 15 though
didn't know 15 and then I was like
yeah I put my stamp on Instagram Twitter
I'm not sure I'll do it on that and
you're gonna pay me cool yeah yeah it's
no big deal and then we get a call from
comedy dynamics and they're like hey
what is Andrew doing anything for a
special my agents like your Netflix
reached out hmm and they're like don't
sign anything give us a second we'll put
something together so we go back to
Netflix with some demands we know
they're gonna say no about but we're
like can he be the first episode can hit
his face on the flyer just [ __ ] that
they're gonna have to run through their
lawyers to like stall for a couple days
but also legit I don't care
yeah I just want I just thought they
were really good comics that were on
this yeah and so I was like that's cool
like these are you know my brothers and
sisters like let's do something fun but
we just need a few days so they come
back my agent comes back and he goes
okay here's the deal and he's like
really excited and he like puts it down
and the deal from comedy dynamics is for
a million dollars and I go man this is
[ __ ] amazing and I'm dude that's
that's awesome great job but tell him
we're not interested and he like had a
heart attack like my agent had a heart
attack because he thought it's a home
run
[ __ ] mean he's like this is what you
want it and I was like no no that was
for the last special so shits changed so
it has to adjust accordingly because I
don't care but I'll put it on YouTube
just as much but how many dynamics is
just the production company the
production company and where did they
want to live van de psyche they would go
and shop it right well we stopped it
together we put we partner right yeah so
we because what my thing with them is we
got a partner we got to be in this
together in every aspect of it creative
etc it's not just like paycheck has done
it's like how we gonna work together an
English it good so I said hey man I
can't I you know that's amazing but I
kids got to be more because that's what
it was last time and if I value what I
do and I feel like it's increased value
then you got to respect that and at the
end of the day I've never paid any of my
bills off of money from a special I'll
put my special on YouTube still happily
yes so [ __ ] I'd sell more tickets
doing that I might you know what I mean
or I got some good play conference where
we're going with it I can't say just yet
but but basically you know we sit back
and and my agent had a [ __ ] heart
attack I was he just trust me man just
[ __ ] trust me and then I drop that
crowd work special okay
like 30 40 minutes yeah I was like make
35 minutes and he was like what do you
do like we have things I'll just [ __ ]
trust me everything's fine and the
crowds were special hit a million views
and then we got the offer that was right
and then we were like Netflix thank you
very much but we're gonna go with commie
dynamics and then and then we just
settled with a place that we're gonna
because because I don't see so it's
gonna be on see so long story so I want
to make the announcement in my space
it's why it's a [ __ ] it's no it is it
really interesting is that there's a so
Judd Apatow has this it's a baseball
Network they're doing baseball and
comedy and so I think I'm gonna be the
first cool day I guess the point I'm
trying excited for you just [ __ ] I
can't wait gonna be that I can't wait
just do like I guess what like last time
probably we were on here and we're had
these conversations and I do believe
like Congress you should share all your
[ __ ] but when given the opportunity to
sell it it's important to get your value
were yeah mm-hmm
you know and I think that's why this was
important for me it was like make sure
to make sure people know that there's
there's a reason you're doing there's a
em road to all this right now we're not
we're not destroying the industry we're
just shaking it up so that we can work
together in a better way cuz we're doing
more than we did right it's not [ __ ] I'm
it's hey let's [ __ ] with each other like
a list on a chip yeah I don't work for
you yeah work together look how much
we're doing all three of us tomorrow can
go film an hour and we can put it up on
our YouTube and get millions of views
mm-hmm we know our value you're right so
get paid accordingly you know and even
if you don't get paid put on YouTube and
then blow the [ __ ] up with it yeah we
got all the options yeah it's it's it's
a it's a new way and it's also so young
so it's hard it's a hard it's a hard
medium I mean you've got anyway your
shits gonna be [ __ ] dope on where it
ends up on tick tock or C so it's gonna
be right
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]